[Music]
earthquake
louder with crowder is brought to you in
part by
dot com you don't have to be a
freeloader your whole
life the good news is that you can
support this show
and the fight by buying some really cool
clothes.com
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
changed
[Music]
easy oh disgusting satisfyingly
disgusting
7-up
no faygo
moon mist for all you glows and
juggalettes out
there anyway welcome to louder with
crowder with
dave landau today that's me uh steven is
out right now he's pre-taping some stuff
because as you know he's gonna be going
into surgery
getting that baboon heart put in oh yeah
right
better heart yeah a better heart much
better but
a bigger heart i don't think you can get
him a bigger heart
no i think that's the problem there's
not enough space no there's nothing it's
too large it's
killing him it's just too big of a heart
oh yeah that's what i think
he's the grinch at the end of the story
yes he is yeah
yes when it grew three sizes and anyone
else would collapse
yeah that's actually the diagnostic tool
they used on steven was that magnifying
glass
really broke and it was like they they
brought in a crying little girl
and makes that sound like it through
three sizes cindy lou
well today we are we've got gerald a
howdy we've got angel angela ahoy
there you go you're a little and ahoy
everyone hey
yes we got tiny tim tebow i don't know
why
we got quarter black what's up what's
going on hey my personal fave no offense
to you guys
stop it crawl daddy where are you at
baby where are you
oh boy oh i do i do it i do not awkward
at all
what no i'm fighting it's it's like at
the end of uh
that uh wizard of oz where it's i'm
gonna miss you the most
whatever lion man what about the rest
yeah it's like thanks and just you the
most and you the moment you're the most
you don't understand them
just go commit suicide oh wow
the tin man just goes and stands in the
ring that's the cowardly lion's way out
all right glad to be back in the chair
today enough of that anyway
yes today we'll be talking about
juneteenth being made a federal holiday
it's my time that's right
congratulations to quarter black
and what and what that means for america
we'll also be hitting biden's german
shepherd champ don lemon pushing
critical race theory
and a climate organization inspired by
greta thunder
shutting down over racism we'll also be
hitting newest victoria's secret model
megan
rappano is that correct that's correct
rappano being canceled for an
old tweet the michigan attorney general
going
full tiltarian mode and fabletics and
adidas
newest advertisement strategies so go
ahead watch
and uh right now we're going to see this
oh
if you uh if you get it get ready just
don't throw up
it's james corden and his uh vaccine
video
let's check it out guys
[Music]
well i've seen enough
[Laughter]
i already hate it
very gay yeah is that dora closet
oh we're vaccinated let's get day drunk
oh good santa that beard is on his wife
oh my goodness yes it's not his
huh oh boy
what city is this supposed to be
there's no city that looks like this a
set in l.a
it's the new york street in l.a because
new york there would be
fecal matter everywhere you'd be dodging
it like
can't do dance moves oh a fouchy
trampoline that's cool it makes you
bounce up and down like the way he goes
with his instructions
i never actually wished for a drive-by
no
airy oh why
[Music]
oh stop you do not go to the gym the gym
he goes to is
it just has a pool and towel boys
swimming's a workout too who is this
oh go faster car was that ricky lake
i don't think so they're reaching back
[Music]
oh no throw that couch away
but we know it's not in oklahoma because
they have the right to mow them
yeah that's
trafficking oh good
[Music]
what is that oh it's a luggage cart at
any point let me know when i can turn
this off
oh it's now now's good well that was
terrible
oh i'm sorry i feel i feel a polyp
you're not getting out of it
what is with every i don't even i hope
we're allowed to say this on here
because who knows what you're even
allowed to say
what is with every talk show host
singing about vaccines
and doing cartoons and such and it's
about it
it's just weird it's strange like can
you ever imagine johnny carson coming
out and like yeah oh no not the new
polio vaccine
[Laughter]
you may have your dates a little off but
i
i just remember johnny's sign-off
episode that was about it
and then they brought in leno and
letterman and then ever since it's all
been crap
yeah just always downtown just endless
big
what did he say you can finally go to a
movie is that what he said you can do
you know a movie inside you know a movie
you're not going to go to cats
nobody doesn't nobody went to that i
think they should combine cats and rent
and call it feline aids
that's what late night has become yeah
is a guy singing and dancing on a
i do you ever watch the uh carpool
karaoke
no and you're just like oh just i'm not
saying this should happen i'm just
saying it would be interesting to see
the car get t-boned especially if it's
if it's not an axe you like like if he's
just in there with you two and all of a
sudden
just take him out a garbage truck hits
the side of it
yeah it doesn't have to get on the
driver's side just on whoever the guest
is yeah exactly
yeah that's the rating and just watch uh
james gordon dance out of the wreck
i'm not bleeding anymore
[Laughter]
so we are on instagram we're also on
tick tock because
unfortunately that exists uh it's a
platform
yeah it's a live show monday through
thursday at 10 a.m
you can go to mug club live chat and
please comment comment comment after
this and
i'm going to go ahead and plug myself
you can see me this weekend comment
comment comment about um about you this
will be seeing you this week
about seeing me this weekend buffalo new
york and then next week at big l's and
emily mini emily minnesota there you go
big elves i'm looking forward to it the
guy who runs is a really really nice guy
nice be july one and two then i'm going
to be in like des moines and a few
other places over this little break we
have tickets for this weekend's show
because people keep
you know finding out that it sells out
really quick they sell out
quicker than me for a paycheck there you
go ah
there you go so here we go guys are you
ready for this
yeah i don't know if you've heard the
big news last week juneteenth was made
of federal holidays
yep so that means
nothing ah
yeah all right congratulations to
everyone
how do you feel about that qb really
good you know i feel like uh reparations
have been paid and uh we can move on
as long as you got a holiday are we just
not taking the time to say 19th
uh it's ebonics okay well i i mean i
think i
just want to be current they asked the
lgbtq aaip plus community
that's okay to take one of their days is
a.i artificial intelligence i don't
believe so
yes it is
i don't know what anything means anymore
well no one does no one does
it that's all you get in trouble for
everything right it's all a riddle
you can just make something up i bet you
could offend somebody just in the middle
of a store and be like you didn't call
that a peacock
ah they're like what you're like well
it's a person who eats
uh pistachios of color
uh speaking of people of color jessie
smallett
hey jesse josie's justice millet yes
jesus malay happy birthday he turns
39 oh good isn't that great yeah does he
still have a career
i don't know he barely made it though if
we remember that story i'm so glad he
was able to survive
uh in honor of his birthday subways
actually decided to induct jessie
into its hall of fame alongside other
prestigious inductees
like jared jared's pants and crying
children
oh okay
[Laughter]
[Applause]
country oh my god also in that hall of
fame wet meats
have you ever had a dry meat in a subway
they're all slimy
and not even wet slimy anytime i see a
subway i just think your spokesperson uh
had kitty porn yeah like that's you
can't have a place
is he still doing time what happened to
jerry he's got to still be doing time i
think they beat the crap out of him too
yeah really yeah for the sandwich
oh yeah he's gonna get a lot of them in
prison
what if jared's in there holding it down
he's head of a gang and he's got these
face tattoos oh yeah made a hard turn
he's just got a
cold cut combo tattoo
now i bet he's not i bet he's just
getting raped
if there's any justice
oh my god oh hey have you well i bet you
this is every time somebody gets to a
prison
hey how you doing you want to uh rape
the subway guy we do that
all right first week here you get your
rape this way you guys are right
it's in their pamphlet by the way he is
still in prison currently
there we go i hope he stays there well
he deserves to stay there for quite a
while
yeah well i would say quite i would say
till uh till death
yeah till the end of time yeah that
would be i think when he dies his bones
should stay within the prison walls
i agree they should sentence to 15 years
and eight months
that's it that's it wow 15 years that's
pretty old for him
all of the kids he looked at will have
aged out by them yeah
he looks that is he he considers it
three
five-year-olds all right so can i split
it up
yeah you're costing me four generations
judge
double digits disgusting all right so
let's ask this question of the day what
do you think is actually driving racial
tension in america
systemic racist comment let us know is
it systemic racism
is it uh the movie white men's burden
with john travolta
that oh it's one of those things it's
one of the two if anyone had seen it
that might be a fact yeah i watched it
and i was like this isn't good
here's here's me after any movie with
john travolta
well that was terrible you keep going
back expecting a different result
yeah did you see god jenner's man i did
not oh you have to
no i hear it's terrible it's why oh stop
it i don't want to watch something
no his performance in the o.j simpson
that was stellar oh
that made that oh my goodness he was so
bad that made it
like he was just terrible oh my lord but
you know was good the guy that played uh
cochrane yes yeah he was awesome very
good he made a watch
no it wasn't cuba um he played oj he was
oj
no it was i forget his name uh he's from
detroit though he
at least went to wayne state university
the guy who plays him but nokuba was
uh he's in some sexual troubles i
believe
yeah yeah huh yeah well sorry brother
that's snowden
baby though abc's that's
his character he won an oscar for the
worst
performance ever what what did he win an
oscar for jerry maguire
oh i thought he was good yeah no no no
no he was not no he's just show me the
money and they're like well i guess here
oh there's more catchphrase this equals
denzel and glory what's the difference
yeah clearly there's the equal
caliber who was the up against that year
was that it was it was
it that level like denzel no yeah that's
like if you look at what people have won
for okay yeah i don't know i just wasn't
a big fan of jerry mcguire but i think
tom cruise is a bit
weird i don't mind his height what a hot
take
thank you yeah hot take i i yeah i try
let's talk about uh well so anyway
speaking of of uh
speaking of uh anything eddie jared
being cancelled
and cancelled biden's german shepherd
champ died over the weekend yeah
one of his beloved german shepherds
champ died which is sad
uh but we actually have a lead on the
cause of champ's death
from a deleted tweet exclusively
released
to this show about to go
on a walk with the clinton's wolf
big mistake dogs are so trusting
they really are they really are and you
know it's a dog who tweeted it because
it says woof
yeah it's authentic yeah i just r.i.p
champ
r.i.p is that the one that broke his leg
by petting him
maybe that's joe remember yeah because
joe broke his leg right while playing
with a dog
that's heroic yeah yeah how'd you break
it well i bent over to pet champ
yeah i i touched a poodle and my knee
went out
also i'm gonna be president yeah joe we
have people for that now
yeah pet my dog
oh he's the worst all right so anyway
don lemon
let's talk about this don lemon don
lemon
last week don lemon and chris cuomo
talked about the great critical race
that what great
how great how great i meant to call it
the great critical race theory because
it is
but how great how great critical race
theory is
and that white people should just stop
making everything about themselves
so if you are the person who happens to
be telling the history you're going to
tell it in your favor
and the best way to correct that so that
some people aren't over indexed in the
history of the country
is to have all voices as many voices as
possible
included in that history people don't
like to have
their pleasure interrupted their peace
interrupted
and so people think that it should be
the way that it should be because they
have been taught that
in in this country but you know
telling people having people come to the
realization especially
ancestors of slaves that they they were
enslaved and that they were beaten that
they were sold that they weren't able to
accrue well that they weren't able to go
to school they want to go vote you think
that makes them feel good
so the folks on the other side stop
making it about you
and be curious instead of judgmental
right that's all
i get that you know for sure fourth of
july is gonna roll around i'm still
gonna have my juneteenth decorations up
what exactly are those um i i'll tell
you officials
you can't you can't say you really do
you realize he said he said that folks
on the other side
you know what that means yes he can't
say white folk why people you can't do
that
yes they focus on the other side it's
very strange i
don't know it well in on on sunday don
lemon said in an
interview with washington post magazine
that
i don't know if america sees black
people and especially black gay men
is fully human as and as deserving of
the american dream
what where are you getting this
information well this is that is
obviously
not true right america is not an
inherently racist racist nation
and everyone is fully human regardless
of race i think we can agree yeah
even you rosie o'donnell
[Laughter]
we make exceptions i mean stretching it
we're stretching it a bit huh
because she's gross but
what what's so bad about critical race
theory uh the
the lemon is pushing in my opinion you
know we've learned we've talked about it
on the show
a bunch but since it's coming up so
frequently we want to explain
it a little bit more in depth critical
race theory is based on the idea that
racism is systemically embedded
in american institutions not just the
results of individual prejudices and
stereotypes
these conclusions are drawn from
decades-old
uh policies like redlining and
segregation
yeah which you know a bit about right
yeah so and i
understand like there are definitely
instances where redlining was a bad deal
where you just circled an area on the
map and said
regardless we're not giving people from
this area alone and we're not going to
do it based on the color of skin but i
was thinking about this this morning and
i thought look
you might be 100 right or you might be
50 right or 25 right maybe people
that did go get a you know submitted
loan application trying to get a home
loan couldn't
get the loan because they couldn't
afford it hey by the way i moved 13
times before i graduated high school
we didn't rent houses and move from
apartment to apartment and go for to
three
third grades because people looked at my
dad and said oh he's white i'm not gonna
give him a loan we couldn't
make the payments on the loan so they
were like this is money we're not gonna
give it to you because it's not a good
investment for us
there were probably tons of that going
on and i'm sure tons of racism going on
back in the 1930s what they're talking
about with redlining and even sometimes
after that
but you can't just look at one instance
and that's how they're teaching it well
this is because of redlining not because
people couldn't afford the homes
not because they didn't have enough
income to show it was just racism across
the board
and i think that's that's painting it
with too broad of a stroke you don't
really get at the actual problem if you
do that
so no i think it's really well put
especially because i'm pretending to
know more about this than i do
what's shaking i just had no idea that
third grade was
three hard years on gerald i know well
and he moved 13
no no i went to one third one third
grade year but three different schools
that must have been tough on you okay
yeah i mean my mom was surprised she was
like
you're not moving up good job no these
kids really didn't like you to move
13 times everywhere you went yeah you
couldn't make a friend
five different elementary schools two
middle schools one high school
we used to call it flunking do they
still use it
[Music]
[Laughter]
you can't fail me if i don't go here see
yeah
that's right even with like housing
loans and all that
it drives me nuts because we also give
out terrible housing levels
we decided to make sure it was all equal
the 2008 housing crisis is what happened
it was predatory home lending it's the
exact opposite right what you just said
and then we blamed the american we
blamed the black american the white
american any american home buyer by
saying
oh it was your fault for buying
something that was way out of your price
range
when you were sold this by a company and
then backed by a bank
like it was your fault then all this
stuff collapsed and who do we bail out
the banks yep yes that's true they're
allowed to do whatever they want
predatory lending don't you love it well
look there were some loans out there
where people
sold them a bill of goods right of
course like they they should never have
gotten the loan but it
was also because they were pushed to
correct the wrongs this is what happens
when you try to fix something by going
oh well today we'll just do the exact
opposite of what we did back then
and that'll fix everything that's not
how you fix it that's how you create
other problems they're just in a
different direction
yeah that's how it becomes right now
right is
yeah oh it's just you can't yeah doing
the polar opposite of the way things
have always
done and make it so sudden that's the
problem with everything going on i think
right now in the country is you want
this sudden
abrupt 180 with absolutely everything
and then punish the people that are
confused by it
yeah i think i'm going to butcher this
quote but i think it was justice alito
who said um
and maybe not it may not have been a
leader so forgive me if it wasn't um
said that it's kind of hard to fix
racism with more racism
right when trying to address it that was
chandler
ah yes supreme court friends you know
whatever
i get them confused sometimes current
drunk pelican
[Laughter]
he looks rough but it's uh and he looks
really bad that reunion should have been
an intervention
yeah really yeah oh that's right he's
got billions of dollars and no brain
uh no discernible talent whatsoever
but if but yeah we talk all right anyway
so it
let's put it as yes schools we really
just discussed schools just last week
rhode island school teacher allison
grico
is that right greiko right not not not
geico
almost i bet it was alison geico she
don't need to be teaching with all that
cash
got all that caveman money so just last
week
rhode island school teacher allison
grico offered extra credit for students
who
testified testified is that right
again all right students who testified
against
i would assume tested but it's testified
against house bill 6070 a bill
that specifically bans teachers from
making individuals feel distressed on
account
of their race or sex so we don't want
that
yeah i'm just i'm just dead
there it is yes exactly thank you bernie
why would you get credit for that i wish
i went to school now i would get all a's
well no look getting credit for
participating in in public discourse is
fine right like hey go out and like be
active in the community it's better than
sitting in the class sometimes and doing
nothing or
going and doing like stupid busy work
homework but she actively sent people to
do this
so that they would protest something
that was keeping teachers from making
people feel distressed on account of
their race or sex that's weird
you don't want them to fight something
like that right or jump into a political
argument for it like how about this
you'll get extra credit if you go
testify on whichever side you come down
on of 60 70 and here's the bill
how do you get your idea how do you feel
some make somebody feel better about
their sexuality
like go out there and make them feel
good like this all right does this feel
good
i thought it worked out weren't supposed
to you don't want to go down here
do you is this making you distressed we
don't want teachers
to do that can you imagine being in
school today imagine steven in school
today
i can't i would just have to rent space
in the principal's office i mean
i'd have to live with the school you
would he said what did he say
this is why i just entered any challenge
i couldn't go to school then
i left every single class i skipped
everything now i would just be like
done no today you'd be in you'd be
engaged you'd be really
you'd be the top student because you'd
be pissed off i would
come in in a neckerchief looking like
paul lind
and just get a's just this show
this show has done so much for paul
lynde lately
you help where you can dug him up oh my
god i would just i'd buy a wheelchair
and blow in it and i'd be like straight
a's
no offense to anybody's handicapped i'm
just saying there seems to be
favoritism in some ways look it's like
water finding its level you'll find the
favoritism wherever it happens
to be yeah you can lead a horse to water
but you can't beat it to death
huh well i don't think that sounds like
is that right i think it's deep
oh no it's make it
okay so um the federal government
um on the first day in office biden
resumed the workplace diversity training
trump had banned from federal agencies
trump's bad idea he didn't do anything
he doesn't even know where he is
this is what he did don't know he didn't
do his handlers
if he probably took the only thing he
did was take a shower while sitting in a
chair
i do dips in here no you don't you get
out of the chair with that you're in
water it doesn't count yeah the guy gets
more random bruises than one of dawn
magic wands [ __ ]
and we're just supposed to go oh yeah
this is what he did today when he woke
up squan's dog
just jumped out of bed with no pain and
fixed everything
oh so trump's mouth banning
sought to eliminate words like white
supremacy and
systemic racism as well as root out
ideologies that label entire groups of
people inherently evil or
racist also known as white people yes so
you mean racist
right just racist racist thing don't
have to define it it's it's just
racist you have to put a word before
racism so white
white white i had a whole speech plan
too about
three dents and a skull uh
executive order resuming this training
mandated the federal government
adv advance racial equality i wish i
could read
racially i really should just read off
of this one
racial equity it's the close one
racial equity in government institutions
the executive order stated the federal
government
government's goal to advancing equity is
to provide
everyone with the opportunity to reach
their full potential
because advancing equity requires a
systematic approach
to embedding fairness in decision-making
processes
execute executive departments and
agencies must recognize and work
to re to redress in a inadequate why is
this so
stupid it's nonsense it really is
nonsense by the way you read it i don't
even care
in their policies and programs that
serve as equal opportunity
look at that equity and opportunity i'll
come back to that cause it doesn't mean
anything
it does to a lawyer yeah that's the only
person who would make sense to
consistent with these aims i didn't mean
to yell i'm sorry to the babies
they might be sleeping assistant to this
aim each agency
must assess whether and what extent its
programs and policies
perpetuate systemic barriers to
opportunities and benefits for people of
color and other undeserved
underserved groups dave's moving it
around like ah how's this joking
when i move it back and forth how you
like looking like you can't breathe
but it's really it's double speak yes oh
a guy that used to go on carson and
would would speak
and say nothing the words worked but in
syntax they made no sense
that's what they're ever every possible
and that's why when i read it i get
frustrated because you're saying the
same words over and over and over again
that's how you manipulate people yeah
that's how you just shove something into
somebody's brain to get them to believe
you is by repeating the same thing
over and over and over and over and over
and over but look what they said
they said opportunity and they said
equity those are two very
different things one is equality the
outcome yeah right you're trying to
ensure the outcome for people
the other one is saying everybody needs
the same opportunity
at some level right where they have the
opportunity to go out and make their
life great it doesn't mean you won't
have challenges i moved 13 times i had
challenges in third grade we've talked
about it yeah you were right everybody
has challenges real
dunce yeah they have challenges that
they have to overcome
the government is basically saying no no
it's about opportunity but it's equity
if you're trying to ensure
equity the only way that you can do that
is to bring everybody down
they've moved to whatever baseline like
recently yeah
exactly and so you're gonna see them say
equity
and then talk about opportunity yeah but
that's not the goal the goal is to
ensure
outcomes and the only way to do that is
to say oh reparations oh we got to get
rid of school loans oh we've got to get
rid of
paying for health care because that's a
human right oh we've got to get rid of
this or that and oh we have to tax the
rich and bring them down
so that everybody's equal that's not the
society we live in we want everybody to
have the opportunity to go
up not stay at a terrible level and
everybody's just equally terrible
that's the american dream and none of
this is the purview of government
no no the referee needs to keep his
whistle in his pocket right now i mean
it's crazy
they're involved in every call well they
screw stuff up more than they make it
better
how often look irs dmv go look at those
things
tell me they work well oh every
government thing you're a part of is
just stellar
yeah you just show up security bankrupt
do you think they're doing a good job
how about the mail like you said right
we spend billions of dollars how about
public education
are you satisfied with the 12 to 15 000
a year that we're spending on each
student in a lot of a lot of states and
have terrible results
uh yes dave's like i fully support the
program yeah i know i love
i think everything that's why i think we
should have gov government health care
we should all make the same way
government cheese
government cheese yeah yeah oh yeah that
stuff's good
i like to light it up you ever make a
good real government chase
good grilled cheese anyway let's move on
sharing is caring in may
documents revealed unless it's oh sorry
we gotta put that up there i mean if
it's well
if you share aids it's not caring at all
well it's legal in california
genital warts yes can't disclose no is
aids legal in california to share
well you don't have to uh say anything
to anybody even if you know
that you have uh the word you don't have
to tell somebody you have aids
no well what am i doing blabbing
zip it all right i didn't even know all
i had to do was go to california and
spread my demons
line up for aids dave all right
that's not a good addition that is not a
good ad i know i'm getting the wrap-up
thing jingle bells
do we want to just cut this part yeah
we'll do this one and maybe
the last one no i like the last one all
right would you rather cut this right
out
all right in may documents revealed
by chris ruffo of manhattan institute
showed lockheed martin
sent executives to a three-day white
male
re-education camp in order to
deconstruct their white male culture
and atone for their white male privilege
wow wow
that sounds dude but what is going on
sounds benign what is going on i want to
meet any guy from that
conference any guy and just talk to him
i can't imagine what kind of kids
go to that does anybody have any balls
anymore really does anyone have the
balls to be like i don't know those
people
i do not recognize them just sitting
there in your cub scout uniform
waiting for the bus to go to white
reform camp yeah
where's sharks in the zombie shame yeah
what do you get badges for
you're like oh this is this is my uh
ally badge
uh this is my uh doesn't say the n-word
anymore bad oh there you go
oh good that's you get nothing okay
my girlfriend has a boyfriend right now
this is my rugs or oriental
not people badge ah oh my god
participants were told to associate the
term white men with
old racist guilty kkk
and founding fathers ah oh that's good
no
well i think the founding fathers and
kkk that's
a good natural connection right it just
makes common sense
damn it he's everywhere what's your
favorite k in clan gerald
when there's none of them do you like
the clucks i used to go to baseball
games it was really awkward when the
pitcher had three strikeouts because it
was just three k's
i know i was just hilarious get to the
fourth switch we should really
do the four strike system here uh
we don't start until you get to no yeah
yeah just weird uh the program
also made participants repeat hundreds
of privileged statements
such as my culture teaches me to
minimize the perspectives and powers of
people of other races
right there i can commit acts of
terrorism violence or crime and not have
it attributed to my race
i black people too like what i don't
know what
are there black terrorists we just did
the npr story where
they did that exact thing they
attributed race to the white guy and
not the black guy weird okay almost like
it happens to everybody
or i am not accused of having made a
choice to be heterosexual
i don't think anyone's accusing you of
that
and in case you didn't know lockheed
martin is
the biggest defense contractor in the
world
oh my god that's good this is this is
terrible
you got to go listen we need you to
associate old white men because those
will be the ones we aren't hitting with
bombs
right by the way if you can go find the
series of tweets that revealed all this
information go out there it's on twitter
i think the links will be on the website
read through all the other things like
it's like saying hard work and
you know personal responsibility and
other things are are like
they they oppress black people it
literally
said that it was like oh my gosh i can't
even anymore that is the most racist
thing that i've heard i've ever say
saying
hard work to a black man would be
oppressive how how do you
what do you think of black people
they're hard-working too what the hell's
the matter
with bigotry it's so true unbelievable i
don't even know if it's it's it is soft
bigotry but it's now become hard
yeah without them even noticing that
they're doing it they're like well a lot
of straight phobia there too did you
notice yeah oh yeah
very straight phobic i do not enjoy
people
accusing me of being heterosexual i mean
i
am oh yeah right usually and by the way
i wasn't i think we're going to skip the
uh college was the greatest
thing oh let's just go right through it
okay well we're going to skip well
that's fine
i didn't mean to rant and ramble i just
like having a chit chat
let me sum it up yes freda soon berg's
racist organization not her not her
organization has claimed that they are
racist in new zealand and has decided to
disband
that's all you need to do okay well
let's let's uh let's get rid of it then
how dare you
there it is i dare i dare why are we
still listening to her
well um i don't she turned again
honestly
her biggest fans were like yuck
[Laughter]
jared unfollowed her very quickly from
prison yeah i don't even hear any more
about it
was it acid rain that's still a big
thing or was that the 80s i think that
was the remember toto bless the reins
down in africa
god bless the reigns it's a great song
yeah it is
that's what i use at the gym
you guys know megan rappano right yeah
yeah well she she put a tweet and uh we
we covered her last week
uh with her role as replacing the
victoria's secret angels
and uh after the show however uh she was
canceled for a tweet
uh involving the u.s soccer player uh
natasha kai i believe from may 2011 they
found this tweet
okay and what this read was um
yeah i can't it's no rough i can't do
that
this is you know i believe in i believe
in cancel culture but
i don't believe in cancer culture i
should say but some things
some things are just hate speech you
know sometimes they're just across the
line
yeah i'm going to go ahead and bring in
is troy jr here could troy jr come in
and maybe
field this one because i don't want to
be a be a part of the actual
hey austin hey or what are you excels
around here
yeah all right um read this
um okay what's this it's uh
it's a tweet from uh
megan okay okay the new victoria secret
model
okay so let me read this yeah uh
megan rapinoe at tasha
underscore kai zero zero you
look asian with those
closed eyes
[Music]
uh i i i don't understand how she
how she could say this austin
sorry buddy
[Music]
i hope you saw that megan yeah yeah
we'll wait an apology
you broke an asian boy's spirit yeah
congratulations
and and we tried to and couldn't
i can't believe he got out of here that
quickly with those binded feet
they look adorable i know they really
are nice little tiny foods
yeah so let us know what you think of
megan rapinoe's tweet
comment comment comment below yeah and
go ahead and say
you know if you want to tell austin how
you feel he is
really seriously hurt right now you need
time he's broken he's broken
yeah so um do we have to jump up i think
we've got a couple minutes we can do
this
we gotta or should we do the uh all
right the bottom one
yeah there we go yeah good job let's do
this one
yes i like this one all right it's so
much fun we just
end up not having enough we just start
chit chatting right crawdaddy that's
right
we do the old it's like chocolate the
old grannies chit chat
i'm actually wearing a joe shirt by the
way joe lewis nice and i got the rink
right in the middle there
it's not it's not there anymore ah but
if it were i bet you they'd have monster
truck rallies have they torn down jeremy
i don't know i i said that without
really knowing
but just guess they were certainly
talking about how they were going to do
it
and but usually they save it for
terrible events and then it closes
okay which is yeah monster truck rallies
or and supercrawl
supercross bring your mullet bring your
kid bring your black-eyed wife
bring me bring a baby bottle filled with
mountain dew
sunday sunday sunday start them early
jolt cola for babies
trash is detroit dragway still there i
don't want to go down a rabbit tree i
don't know if detroit dragon waste
that was it in the country for a while
yeah that was there i don't know if it's
still they do still have the grand prix
oh sure yeah and then they have uh the
you know various boat shows
sometimes yeah boat races boat races
they do and then my friend's dad drives
a boat right fill it up race away from
detroit
yeah yes it's a it's uh it's right on
the detroit uh river
and they do these boat races my friend's
dad honestly brought us there it was the
first time i've ever had someone's
father
drink and drive me somewhere
and the whole time he just had a he had
a coke koozie
around his bud light and he's just
slamming them and when we pulled up a
cop saw and was like better keep that
hidden
there's a bit of privilege put that
under the seat yeah yeah
well speaking of uh athletes and
being athletic yeah uh adidas and
fabletics
uh have decided to put out uh i guess
for lack of a better term
they call it this fat promos all right
all right adidas and fabletics are using
morbidly obese models to show off their
new workout gear
um adidas will now actually feature
advertisements with the band
can't run dmc yeah i can't wait
they all get stung by bees what happened
no bro
carbs barbs yeah there's
the white man's carbs that's what it is
there's too many empty calories
starch you know what it is is racism is
filled with empty gallery
so they're just balloon damn it that's
what it is yeah now we're not
now we're not saying fat people
shouldn't work out actually
we encourage it it's just not a good
message to send to young girls that
being
morbidly obese is healthy and normal but
a bunch of other athletics
companies have also followed yeah so i
think we should mention that like
nike's new slogan is just donut uh
no uh bad idea puma is uh rebranding
itself as
fupa okay do the math on that one that
is
fat upper p area ah oh
didn't have to do the math
i did it for us thanks dave or as i call
it
for some reason every substitute teacher
i've ever had that was a female
always had their genes yeah right up to
here and you're like how big
how big is that gina
[Laughter]
to where you have to urkel your pants
like every one of them just look like a
fatty arbuckle in a silence new balance
will now be called no balance okay and
it's changing its slogan from let's make
excellent happen to
let's make excellent waffles i'm on
board for that one
i like that one had waffles and uh
gerald a do you want to field this one
sure
under armour use the slogan the only way
is through
it will now be the only way to the
hospital is through a removed wall and a
crane out onto a flat bed while papers
watch
oh my gosh yeah this is my 600 pound
life it's wordy everywhere it is
it is wordy but that's what happens when
you you have to
cut a hole in the wall and crane people
out do you ever watch richard simmons
will be their spokesman yes he will
he's pulled a few people out of picture
windows hasn't he has
he's done it yeah but i understand he's
trained in a basement with dealing meal
cards
terry jerry springer yeah some guy
kidnapped him oh
no it's this housekeeper or his house
yeah yeah right angela's scary
it's gotta be weird to look for a
housekeeper you're like what are you
looking for
besides a clean house i don't know could
you abuse me
yeah do me a favor and like don't abduct
me that's all i really
want to take all my money
oh you know how you sweat to the oldies
i want to sweat wondering if i'm going
to make it through the day
will i eat it's a different kind of work
move groove and lose
so awesome we got to jump off this
platform if we're still on it
uh i noticed so far so good we didn't
say anything
yeah the least bit offensive and i'm
friends with dmc from run dmc i'll admit
that on this show
well it's why not because i like to name
drop my adidas look it's just too cool
of a band not to say you know the guy
yeah come on come on come on
they they basically invented modern day
rap
and then rap rock with walk this way
with aerosmith love it
yay yay that's actually ice cube that's
not you
i don't like when ice cube goes on a
talk show and he's like yay it's like
just sit down dude
sit down and do the interview daddy day
camp
so anyway we're gonna go ahead and jump
off of here remember you can see me live
dave landau.com we got
minnesota all kinds of places also
comment comment comment
go to the store we also have awesome new
shirts they're really really great
i just grabbed a few myself shark jail
we got uh
fight like hell of do you still fight
like hell we do that one's one of my
so finn again oh finnegan thomas
finnegan
be sure to buy that one because thomas
doesn't like it
yeah so he doesn't like it at all he
pisses him off yes
and speaking of piss off why don't we go
ahead and piss off youtube you